اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
طرفان نزاع في السودان يبحثان تمديد
الهدنه في جده اليوم وشروط جديده على
طاوله التفاوض
توتر متزامن في ليبيا شباكات عنيفه في
طرابلس وغارات لليوم الرابع على مدينه
الزاويه
تحت شعار مئويه تركيا اردوغان يدشن حقبه
جديده وكليتشار اوغلو يتوعد بمواصله
الكفاح
الموازنه تشعل ازمه جديده بين بغداد
واربيل والاخيره تحذر من الاخلال بالاتفاق
السياسي
صباح الخير رغم كل ما تخللها من خروقات
وتعطيل لايصال المساعدات تتوجه انظار
السودانيين اليوم مره اخرى صوب جده على
امل ان تفضي المفاوضات الجديده الى تمديد
الهدنه والاهم تثبيتها الاجتماع المرتقب
بين طرفي النزاع سيعقد اليوم قبيل انتهاء
مهله الهدنه لكن على وقع معارك مستمره
واوضاع انسانيه صعبه وموجه نزوح لم تتوقف
لذلك هذه المره يبدو ان هناك شروطا جديده
على طاوله التفاوض مصادر من وفد التفاوض
السوداني كشفت ان الوفد سيتقدم بملاحظات
واشتراطات قبل الدخول في اي اتفاق مع
الدعم السريع وقبل توجه الوفود الى جده
شدد بيان سعودي امريكي مشترك على تمديد
الهدنه واهميتها ووقف النار لمنح المنظمات
الانسانيه فرصه لايصال المساعدات البي
الامريكي مشاهدينا اكد رصد انتهاكات
للهدنه واستخدام طرفي النزاع طائرات
عسكريه ومسيرات في المعارك واستغلال
المنشات الصحيه والمستشفيات لاغراض عسكريه
حول ذلك ينضم الينا من القاهره الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني حمور زياده اهلا بك معنا
سيد زياده اذا في ظل الخروقات المستمره
وفي ظل الاشتباكات المستمره رغم الهدنه ما
فرص تمديد الهدنه الان في التفاوضات التي
تحدث في جده للمره الثانيه
نعتقد انه الطرفين يعني مكرهين على القبول
بوساطه الدولتين السيرتين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
سيوافقان على تمديد الهدنه انا اعتقد ان
المجتمع الدولي يحاول ان يجعل الهدنه امرا
واقعا الهدنه الاسبوع الماضي لم تحقق اي
شيء من اغراضها لم تتوقف العمليات الحربيه
لم يكن هناك امكانيه لوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه
للمواطنين لكن اصبحت الهدنه امرا واقعا
اعتقد ان المرحله الجديده لن تكون مرحله
يعني النقاش فيها حول هل سيكون هناك خدنا
ام لا بل سيكون النقاش حول ان تكون خدنا
فاعله ولو بمقدار قليل يعني على الاقل
تقليل حده الاشتباكات
والمحوريه ربما سيد زياده يعني ما الغرض
من تمديد الهدنه اذا كان هناك مازال
خروقات بالتالي ما هي برايك الملاحظات
والاشتراكات التي يضعها الطرفان
اليوم في جده
حتى هذه اللحظه ليس لدي معلومات كافيه لكن
اذا كان لي ان استنتج فانا اعتقد ان سيكون
هناك مطالبات للدعم السريع بالخروج من
المستشفيات هذا امر خطير ما زال مستمرا
هناك ايضا عمليه التعدي على منازل
وممتلكات المواطنين هناك حاله نهب كبيره
يقوم بها عدد من المنتمين لقوات الدعم
السريع اذا لم تستطع قياده الدعم السريعه
السيطره على هذه الانتهاكات فاعتقد انه
يعني انه لن يكون هناك اي معنى لاي اتفاق
معها بوقف اطلاق النار او بهدنه انسانيه
في تقدير ان هذه الامور التي ينبغي ان
توضع في الطاوله اولا لا اعرف هل سيكون
هذا ما سيهتم به وفد الحكومه ام لا لكن من
المؤكد ان هذا ما ينبغي الحديث عنه اولا
طيب يعني سيد زياده انت في القاهره ولكن
ما المعلومات الوارده لديك من السودان ومن
مناطق الاشتباكات في الساعات الاخيره من
هذه الهدنه هل هناك مازال خروقات هل هناك
اي تصعيد في ذلك
نعم ما زالت الخروقات مستمره من الجانبين
امس طبعا صدر بيان عن الدولتين الميسرتين
رصد هذا البيان بعض الانتهاكات من الطرفين
والخروقات التي تمت للهدنه وبعد البيان
تواصلت هذه الانتهاكات والعمليات الحربيه
والاشتباكات في عدد من الاماكن لكن طبعا
يعني هناك الان
بسبب النزوح الكبيره الذي حدث في العاصمه
الخرطوم يمكن ان نقول ان الاضرار المدنيه
اصبحت اقل قليلا لكن اكثر الاخبار هي
تتحدث عن اقتحام المنازل الخاليه هناك
احياء كامله اخليت من سكانها اصبحت مفتوحه
للعصابات واصبحت مفتوحه لقوات الدعم
السريعه التي تنشر هي نفسها فيديوهات
تتفاخر فيها باقتحام البيوت وسرقتها
طيب شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني حمور زياده
في السودان ايضا تتفاقم ازمه الخبز بسبب
الحرب في ظل شح الدقيق في المخابز التي
اغلق كثير منها او اغلق ابوابه ما دفع الى
اصطفاف طوابير طويله من المواطنين امام
المخابز العامله حيث يضطر كثيرون الى
الوقوف لساعات للحصول على رغيف الخبز فيما
لجا اخرون الى المنتجات البديله للخبز من
مصنعات الدقيق والذره
وكان ازمات السودان تطول ولا تخسر تتجدد
كل حين لكن بظروف مختلفه هذه المره اقلقت
كثير من المخابز ابوابها بعض 40 يوم من
اندلاع الحرب في الخرطوم الاختتال
والانتشار العسكري ادى لنفاذ الدقيق داخل
المخابز والى توقف الامداد الوقوف
والانتظار لساعات طويله بات هو السبيل
الوحيد المتاح للحصول على خبز والافران
كله هناك مقفل
ما في دقيق
شغال في
الرابع هنا الصباح ليوم الليله الساعه
قريب ما شرط نار الصلاه
يعني كل يوم انت بتصبح الصباح انه الحكايه
متعزمه يعني متازيه الافران ماشيه في
تكفيل زياده كل يوم في زياده في ازمه
بتاعه صفوف ثقيله فصاحب من الساعه سته
طبعا مشيت
فالوضعك صعب يعني
لا يبدو ان هناك حلولا عمليه لصد النقص اذ
ان اغلاق المخابز ستواصل فيها كذا اوضاع
حسبما يقول اصحابها المشاكل في الدقيق
الغاز ما في وفرض الدقيقه اللي عندنا ما
تقضي يوم ولا يوم الثاني
ما في وجود الالغاز ولا الدقيق ولا على
الخميره
في ظل شحي وصعوبه الحصول عليه لجا عددا من
السودانيين الى بدائل قديمه حلها تعوض
صعوبه الحصول عليه فقد تسيدت منتجات الذرى
موعد عدد كبير من المواطنين بقينا نفتش
بدائل القراصه الكسره المكرونه الرز
والمكرونه والحاجات دي كلها
في الحاجات دي المهم كل شيء ما في الوضع
صعب جدا جدا
اقلقت كثير من مخابز الخرطوم ابوابها امام
المواطنين لكنهم يعملون رغم تطاول امض
الحرب ان تظل ابواب اخرى مفتوحه امامهم
لمنحهم قدره الاكمال والاستمرار شهد نادر
لقناته العربيه والحدث اندرمان
ولرصد الاوضاع الميدانيه والانسانيه من ام
درمان ينضم الينا الصحفي مقداد حسن اهلا
بك معنا مقداد اذا ابدا معك حيث انتهى
التقرير بالاوضاع الانسانيه لا خبز لا
دقيق لا خميره يبحثون عن بدائل لايجاد
لقمه عيشهم او لقمه يومهم حتى بالتالي في
ظل الخروقات المستمره وفي ظل الانتهاكات
والسيطره على المستشفيات كيف هو الوضع
الانساني في ام درمان تحديدا حيث انت
تحياتي اليك فاطمه والى المشاهدين نعم
الاوضاع الانسانيه تزداد صعوبه يوما بعد
يوم خصوصا ونحن نتحدث عن اكثر من اربعين
يوما لامتداد هذه الحرب نعم هنالك جزء من
الانفراج القليله في الاحياء وانا اتحدث
عن الانفراج في الاحياء التي هي بعيدا
نسبيا من الاشتباكات وايضا كانت فيها
الحركه نسبيه قبل اثناء هذه الاشتباكات عن
الاحياء التي تبعد من المناطق
الاستراتيجيه هنالك بدء الانسياب بعض
المساعدات الانسانيه في جنوب مدينه درمان
حيث
بحسب المعلومات التي وصلت الينا ان برنامج
الغذاء العالمي مع بتنسيق مع الهلال
الاحمر وزع جزء من المساعدات الغذائيه في
تلك المناطق وكذلك بحسب ما علمنا في
مستشفى النوم بشمال مدينه ام درمان وصلت
مساعدات طبيه من قاعده وادي سيدنا
العسكريه في اليومين الماضيين هي بالكاد
تكفي حوجه اربعه ايام لوحده غسيل الكلى
وبالتالي فان وصول المساعدات في حد ذاته
يعني قليل جدا مقارنه مع
العباءات الاول او الامكانيات التي تستطيع
ان تقدمها المستشفى فبالتالي هنالك يعني
شحف هذه الامدادات سواء كانت طبيه او
غذائيه هنالك انفراجه قليله جدا في موضوع
الخبز باعتبار ان الدقيق بدا ينساب بصوره
نسبيه لكن مازالت الطوابير في المخابز وما
زال الناس يعانون في احتياجاتهم الاساسيه
هذا على وجه العموم في مدينه ام درمان
وكذلك الحال هو الاصعب
نعم بحسب المعلومات التي توصلنا اليها لا
وجود لمساعدات في مدينه الخرطوم على وجه
الخصوص باعتبار ان جبهات القتال فيها
تحتدم بصوره كبيره جدا وان هنالك توترات
امنيه خصوصا وان كثير من الاحياء يعني
اخليت تماما واصبحت
محله معارك مستديمه في الايام القليله
الماضيه وكذلك كثير من السكان اخذ هذه
المناطق خصوصا مدينه بحري المواطنين
يعانون في في الخدمات الاساسيه بصوره
كبيره جدا خدمات المياه والكهرباء نسبه
لان
ان فرق الصيانه والتوصيل لا تستطيع ولا
تتوفر لها ممرات انسانيه امنه حتى تصل
وتقوم باعمالها بصوره طبيعيه وامنه هذا في
احياء مدينه بحري والخرطوم في مدينه ام
درمان كذلك هنالك حياه تعاني نفس المشكله
في انقطاع دائم للكهرباء والمياه وشحفي
المواد الغذائيه وانا اتحدث عن الاحياء
الجنوبيه كاحياء المسالمه والركابيه وبيت
المال وبروف وكذلك احياء العباسيه كل هذه
المناطق تشهد فيها الاشتباكات بصوره
مستمره ربما هنالك تمركزات كثيره لقوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المناطق وهي ايضا
قريبه من سلاح المهندسين وبالتالي فهي
يعني في محيط خط النار بين الجهتين هذا ما
يصعب وصول المساعدات الانسانيه وهذا ما
ذكرته البيانات من التي اصدرتها يعني لجنه
الميسرين والمبادرين في وقف اطلاق النار
قصيره الامد بجده وبالتالي فان يعني تمديد
الهدنه القادمه والحديث الان يدور عن
تبليد الهدنه وامكانيه تمديدها بالتالي
يجب ان تفعل هذه الهدنه بصوره حتى تنساب
المساعدات بصوره اكبر وتصل الى المحتاجين
الذين ما زالوا داخل مدينه الخرطوم على
الواقع
من المشاكل اليوميه المستمره شكرا جزيلا
لك من ام درمان الصحفي مقداد حسن
من العنف في السودان الى العنف في ليبيا
فقد اندلع قتال عنيف بين قوات جهاز الردع
واللواء 444 الموالين لحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه وذلك وسط العاصمه طرابلس في ظل
وضع امني مضطرب وتاتي هذه الاشتباكات
مشاهدينا المفاجئه في احياء متفرقه من
العاصمه ردا على قيام قوات جهاز الرضع
الذي يقوده عبد الرؤوف كارا باعتقال احد
قاده اللواء 444 الذي يشرف عليه محمود
حمزه وذلك وسط حشود او حشود عسكريه من
الجانبين وافاد شهود عيان بانهم سمعوا
تبادلا لاطلاق النار اضافه لانتشار المكثف
للاليات العسكريه في محيط طرابلس فيما
تشهد مناطق الاشتباكات تحليقا مكثفا
للطيران المسير الحكومي وبالتوازي ولليوم
الرابع على التوالي تعاني مدينه الزاويه
غرب ليبيا من حاله احتقان مع تنفيذ القوات
المواليه لحكومه الوحده الوطنيه غارات
جويه على عده مواقع في اطار عمليه امنيه
قالت انها تستهدف اوكار التهريب وتجاره
المخدرات حيث اغلقت ميليشيات مسلحه الطريق
الساحلي الرابط بين العاصمه طرابلس ومدينه
الزاويه وذلك احتجاجا على القصف الجوي
الذي تتعرض له المدينه والذي نتج عنه سقوط
ضحايا وخسائر ماديه بحسب مصادر محليه
[موسيقى]
من العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس معنا مراسل
العربيه منير الاشهب اهلا بك معنا منير
اذا وضع مضطرب في العاصمه واشتباكات في
بعض من احيائها كيف هو الوضع الان انقل
لنا الصوره
منير هل تسمعني
طيب يبدو ان منير لا يسمعني ولكن سنعود
اليه حال تمكنا ان نشره مستمره ونتابع
اليابان تضع دفاعاتها الصاروخيه في حاله
تاهب وترقب لاطلاق قمر صناعي من كوريا
الشماليه
اهلا بكم من جديد ونستهل النشره ونعود الى
الملف الليبي في طرابلس ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه منير الاشهب منير يعني حاله
اضطراب تخيم على العاصمه طرابلس واشتباكات
في بعض من احيائها بالتالي كيف هي الصوره
الان هناك انقلها لنا
نعم نعم
تفضل منير
هل تسمع في مشكله في الاتصالات تفضل
منير كنت اسالك عن الوضع الامني هناك هل
مازال هناك اضطراب وحاله توتر في الاجواء
في طرابلس
طيب يبدو ان الارسال هناك صعب بطبيعه
الحال لديك منير شكرا جزيلا لك لانضمامك
لنا من العاصمه الليبيه
تحت شعار مئويه تركيه تحدث رجب طيب
اردوغان عن المرحله المقبله للبلاد بعد
فوزه بولايه جديده وقال في اول خطاب له
بعد اعلانه رئيسا لتركيا انه سيفعل ما
يجعله يليق بثقه ناخبيه كما كانت على مدار
العقدين الماضيين
اشكر كل الاعمال التي بذلها شعبنا وكلفنا
بحمل هذه المسؤوليه لاداره البلاد لمده
خمس سنوات مقبله اشكر شعبنا اذ اناط بنا
هذه المسؤوليه العظيمه ان شاء الله سنفعل
ما يجعلنا نليق بثقتكم وكما كنا جديرين
بثقتكم على مدار الواحد والعشرين عاما
الماضيه ماذا قلت لكم قبلا هذا الحب لا
ينتهي ليس الى يوم الاحد بل الى القبر
والممات
الفائز بالانتخابات الرئاسيه ليس انا بل
الفائز هو تركيا والمنتصر هو الشعب نفسه
بجميع اطيافه والفائز هو الديمقراطيه
في المقابل قال مرشح المعارضه التركيه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كمال كليجدار اوغلو
قال ان الانتخابات كانت اكثر انتخابات غير
عادله في السنوات الاخيره مشيرا الى ان
منافسه استفاد من كافه امكانات الدوله
لكنه شدد على انه سيواصل الكفاح داعيا
مناصريه الى مواصله النضال من اجل
الديمقراطيه
الامه اظهرت رغبتها في تغيير النظام
الاستبدادي رغم كل الضغوط التي تعرضنا لها
حزب الشعب الجمهوري سيواصل النضال على كل
الجبهات وسنكون الرواد لهذا النضال ومهما
قدمنا لهذه الدوله فلن يكون هذا كافيا
لكنني اشعر بالحزن بسبب ما ينتظر امتنا من
صعوبات لكننا سنواجهها وادعو 25 مليون
تركي ممن صوتوا لي ان يواصلوا نضالهم
الى سوريا والتي رصدت بها كاميرا العربيه
افراح السوريين في مدينه اعزاز الواقعه
شمال غربي سوريا بعد فوز الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان بالانتخابات الرئاسيه وما
الامور التي كانت ستقلقهم لو فاز منافسه
المعارض لجدار اوغلو برئاسه التركيه
يعني كنا كتير راح نعاني من موضوع لو فايز
حزب المعارضه منه ترحيل السوريين لسوريا
ممكن سحب قوات التركيه من سوريا في كثير
امور كانت رح تضر السوريين لهيك نحن نبارك
للحكومه التركيه والشعب تركيا بفوز
اردوغان ونتمنى منه يعني لعل وعسى هيك انه
اذا وصل صوتنا لاله انه يقدم هالمنطقه
يدير باله علينا السوريين نحن هون
الموجودين بريف حلب الشمالي مدينه اعزاز
فوز اردوغان منيح ممتاز يعني للشعب السوري
فرحنا كتير انه نجح اردوغان لانه لو مانو
ناجح لو ساقط كان اول شغله عذاب على
اخواتنا السوريين اللي بتركيا يعني مبسوط
من كل قلبي لاني فاز ولو ما فايز ومستلم
منافسه كان وضع السوريين بشكل عام تاذن
بتركيا وان شاء الله الف مبروك للاتراك
وللسوريين الحمد لله رب العالمين اول شيء
انه فاز لانه بالنسبه للسوريين اللي
بالداخل التركي
نزوح وتهجير ثاني وثالث بالنسبه للسوريين
داخل التركي
لم تمضي ليله واحده على اعنف هجوم
بالمسيرات القتاليه على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه منذ بدء الحرب حتى شنت القوات
الروسيه سلسله غارات جويه مكثفه على منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى الا ان الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اكدت انها اسقطت اكثر من 29
طائره مسيره وسبعه وثلاثين صاروخا واشارت
الدفاع الاوكرانيه الى ان كيف شهلت شهدت
ليله اخرى صعبه خاصه انه الهجوم هو الخامس
عشر خلال شهر مايو وحده القياده الجنوبيه
في الجيش الاوكراني قالت ان روسيا وضعت
حامله صواريخ في البحر الاسود في مهمه
قتاليه واشارت القيادات الجنوبيه من ان من
بين الصواريخ الموجوده على متن السفينه
ثمانيه صواريخ من طراز كالبر وقالت في
بيان لها ان ما لا يقل عن ست سفن روسيه
موجوده حاليا في البحر الاسود وواحده في
بحر ازوف مشيره الى ان مستوى التهديد
الصاروخي مرتفع للغايه اما الداخليه
الروسيه فقد وضعت السيناتور الامريكيه
الانسيغرام في قائمه المطلوبين لديها وذلك
بسبب اطلاقه تصريحات وصفتها بالمعاديه
لروسيا خلال لقائه للرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمنسكي
مؤخرا عرف بدعمه لاوكرانيا وتسليحها
ومساعيه لزياده المساعدات العسكريه
الامريكيه للجيش الاوكراني وعرف ايضا بحشد
التاييد الدولي لذلك ومنذ قرار تزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16 الغربيه واعطاء
ضوء الاخضر بنقلها تساءل تساءل يدور في
الاذهان هل فعلا ستغير قواعد اللعبه في
الحرب مع موسكو كما تامل كييف رئيس
الاركان الامريكي صدم الاوكرانيين
بالتاكيد على ان مقاتلات اف 16 لن تصنع
المعجزات لاوكرانيا هذه المره صحيفه
بلومبرج ايضا اوضحت ان هذه الطائرات
الحربيه لن تصمد امام الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه لان اف 16 مزوده برادرات ضعيفه
وذخائر قصيره المدى بخلاف ما تمتلكه
القوات الروسيه وبحسب الصحيفه فان
الرادارات الروسيه الروسيه ستكون قادره
على رصدها قبل ان تقترب لمسافه كافيه
للهجوم وبالتالي يمكن اسقاط هذه الطائرات
من الجيل الرابع ببساطه وافشال الهجوم
وعليه رجح طيارون النكييف ستضطر لتقليص
توقعاتها من تسلم هذا الطراز من المقاتلات
في ملف حرب اوكرانيا مشاهدينا ورد
التقارير اوكرانيه الان في العواجل امامكم
بسماع ذوي انفجارات في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف وان دفاعات الجويه تتعامل مع هجوم
روسي جديد اذا بعد يومين من الهجمات
الروسيه المكثفه على العاصمه يبدو انها لا
تزال العاصمه تتعرض على وابل من الصواريخ
والهجمات الروسيه التي لم تتوقف
اثار اعلان اطلقته كوريا الشماليه بعزمها
اطلاق قمر صناعي كما تقول اثار توترا لدى
طوكيو وسول اليابان وضعت دفاعاتها
الصاروخيه في حاله تاهب واصدرت وزاره
الدفاع اوامر بالاستعداد لتدمير اي صواريخ
كوريه شماليه تهدد اراضيها واعتبر التوكيو
ان اطلاق كوريا الشماليه صاروخا باليسيا
بدعوى انه قمر صناعي هو استفزاز خطير لامن
اليابان
اصدرت وزاره الدفاع وقوات الدفاع الذاتي
امرا للاستعداد لاجراءات تدميريه ضد
الصواريخ الباليستيه ردا على سلسله تحركات
كوريا الشماليه ان اطلاق كوريا الشماليه
صاروخا باليستيا هو استفزاز خطير لامن
بلدنا كما ان عمليات الاطلاق هذه تنتهك
قرارات مجلس الامن الدولي التي تمنع اي
عمليات اطلاق من قبل كوريا الشماليه
باستخدام تكنولوجيا الصواريخ البالستيه
حتى لو كانت تسمى اقمارا صناعيه
خلينا
بجانبها دعت وزاره الخارجيه في كوريا
الجنوبيه دعت بيوم يونغ الى التراجع عن
خطتها لاطلاق صاروخ يحمل قمرا صناعي وقالت
الوزاره انها ستتعاون مع المجتمع الدولي
للرد على ما وصفتها باستفزازات كوريا
الشماليه هذا وتستعد كوريا الشماليه
لاطلاق قمر صناعي في الفتره ما بين 31
مايو وحتى الحادي عشر من يونيو
اذا نذكر مشاهدينا بالاخبار العاجله
الوارده من كييف التي اشارت بها تقارير
اوكرانيه بسماع عدوي انفجارات فكيف
الاداره العسكريه لكي قالت بان الدفاعات
الجويه تتعامل مع هجوم روسي جديد يعني
الهجوم الروسي الذي استمر ليومين ولم
يتوقف حول ذلك ينضم الينا مجددا الصحفي
محمد البابا اهلا بك محمد ما الصوره لديك
انقل لنا هذا الوابل الجديد من الهجمات
الصاروخيه الروسيه على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
تفضل نعم بالفعل يعني قبل
دور سفارات الانذار في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف وبعد اقل من ثلاثه دقائق سمع صوت
انفجار عنيف وبدانا نرى يعني صواريخ تطلق
من الارض باتجاه يعود الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تتعامل مع عدد من الاهداف
الجويه بحسب ما يتداول عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وخاصه تيليجرام ان القوات
الروسيه اطلقت وبالجديد من الصواريخ على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه ولكن المفاجاه ان
الدفاعات الجويه او الانذا قد تم اطلاقه
الى حد ما بوقت متاخر خاصه في ذروه يعني
عند الساعه الحاديه عشر والربع فهي ذروه
وقت العمل في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف دوله
سفارات الانذار توقفت
المترو عن العمل تم دعوه المواطنين للنزول
الى الملاجئ وراينا يعني في اكثر من منطقه
في العاصمه الدفاعات الجويه تنطلق لتصدي
لهذه الضربات حتى هذه اللحظه هناك حاله
حذر ويتداول ان هناك عدد من الصواريخ تطلق
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وهناك يعني الدفاعات الجويه تتعامل مع هذه
الاهداف الجويه يعني هناك حاله ترق وهناك
حال التوتر في العاصمه اصوات الانفجارات
كانت مفاجئه وبعد اقل يعني بعد وقت قليل
من اطلاق الانذار الجوي في العاصمه
الانذار اطلقت بوقت متاخر بالتالي هل تمكن
المواطنين من النزول الى الملاجئ ام لا
يعني هناك الان حركه التوجه الى الملاجئ
لانه يعني منذ حوالي 15 دقيقه او ثمانيه
عشر دقيقه دوت صفارات الانذار لذلك الوقت
ما زال ابو بكر انا يعني كنت في احد
المراكز التجاريه نتبضع طلب فورا من
المواطنين اخلاء هذه
المحال التجاريه فورا والخروج هناك من بدا
يتجه الى الملاجئ هناك من يقف في الساحات
بعيدا عن الابنيه خاصه ان يعني عندما يتم
استهداف الصواريخ او الاهداف الجويه من
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه تتساقط
البقايا الصواريخ او بقايا المسيرات وتسقط
في اماكن غير محدده يعني غير مستهدفه لذلك
هناك يعني دعوات عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي من الجميع بعدم اهمال الانذار
الجوي والتوجه فورا الى الملاجئ حتى
يتداول ان الشبكات المترو قد توقفت وتتحول
في هذه الاسماء الى ملاجئ لواء السكان
شكرا جزيلا لك منك
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع فيها
تحذير في اماكن العمل الاجهاد الرقمي خطر
يهدد الكفاءه والصحه
طرفان نزاع السوداني يبحثان تمديد الهدنه
في جده اليوم وشروط جديده على طاوله
التفاوض
توتر متزامن في ليبيا اشتباكات عنيفه في
طرابلس وغارات لليوم الرابع على مدينه
الزاويه
تحت شعار مئويه تركيا اردوغان يدشن حقبه
جديده
الموازنه تشعل ازمه جديده بين بغداد
واربيل والاخيره تحذر من الاخلال بالاتفاق
السياسي
احييكم من جديد كشف المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان ان الضربات الصاروخيه الاسرائيليه
استهدفت على دفعتين مواقع في محيط دمشق
وريفها ومنطقه المطار الدولي واوضح المرصد
ان اسرائيل استهدفت قاعده دفاع جوي في
دمشق تنتشر فيها عناصر من حزب الله من
جهته اوضح التلفزيون السوري انه تم تفعيل
الدفاعات الجويه بمجرد محاوله اجسام
معاديه اختراق الاجواء السوريه
[موسيقى]
قتل فلسطيني واصيب ثمانيه اخرين برصاص
القوات الاسرائيليه خلال اقتحامها مدينه
جنين والمخيم الملاصق لها وقال شهود عيان
ان قوات من الجيش الاسرائيلي نفذت عمليه
عسكريه واسعه في مدينه جنين شماليه الضفه
الغربيه شاركت فيها عشرات الاليات
العسكريه التي دخلت الى المدينه من اكثر
من محور ما ادى الى وقوع اشتباكات واشارت
تقارير اسرائيليه الى اعتقال خمسه
فلسطينيين خلال عمليه اقتحام عدد من
المنازل في جنين
بس ربنا
الله ينتقم منهم
لا حول ولا قوه
يبدو ان الخلافات لا تنتهي بين بغداد
واربيل هذه المره ساحتها البرلمان
وعنوانها العريض الموازنه الاتحاديه حذف
مواد من الموازنه تخص اقليم كردستان من
قبل اعضاء اللجنه الماليه كان كفيلا
باشعال فتيل ازمه سياسيه جديده
خلافات اربيل وبغداد على فقرتين في مشروع
الموازنه الاتحاديه تمص الصلاحيات
الدستوريه للاقليم الكردي تهدد وبحسب
مراقبينا بانفراط عقد تحالف اداره الدوله
الذي بموجبه شكلت حكومه محمد شياع
السوداني فالاتفاق السياسي ما بين بغداد
واربيل لم يترجم على ارض الواقع بحسب
اربيل بل ان هناك ما وضع العصا في العجله
لايقاف الاتفاق كما توقعنا انهم ينقلبون
على شركائهم دائما غالبيه والاطار
التنسيقي للاسف لا عهد ولا ميثاق لهم وهذه
ليست المره الاولى وكانت متوقعه ولكن
الديمقراط الكردستاني
تعامل معهم بحسن نيه نجح الديمقراطي
الكردستاني في تاجيل التصويت على مشروع
قانون الموازنه الاتحاديه الى اجل غير
مسمى ويسعى الى مناقشه مستفيضه مع شركائه
في تحالف اداره الدوله
بان التعديلات الاخيره للموازنه بمثابه
رصاصه الرحمه للاتفاق
اما في بغداد فالمشهد ينذر بمزيد من
الخلافات بين نواب الاطار التنسيقي من جهه
ونظرائهم من الكرد خاصه بعد تهديد نواب من
الاطار بسحب الثقه من النائب الثاني لرئيس
البرلمان المنتمي للحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني
هذه الخلافات داخل البرلمان سببت حرجا
كبيرا لحكومه السوداني والتي تنتظر اقرار
الموازنه بفارغ الصبر لتنفيذ برنامجها
نامل من خلال الجهود السياسيه التي تحصل
الان
يعني مع مختلف القوى السياسيه على ان نمضي
باتجاه عمليه الاقرار هذا الاسبوع او قد
يكون مطلع الاسبوع المقبل ما يجري هنا في
بغداد يشيب بوجود نوايا لدى اطراف في
الاطار التنسيقي بالتنصل من الاتفاقات
السياسيه التي مهدت لتشكيل حكومه السودان
هنالك قوه اساسا هي تدرك تماما لتلتزم
بهذا التحالف ثالثا تريد ان تحرج الحكومه
حينما ذهبت بمنح الاكراد رواتبهم لعده
اشهر هذه مساله اضافه الى كل هذا هذه
القوه اساسا قسم منها لا تؤمن وان كانت
بائتلاف اداره الدوله لا تؤمن بمفهوم
الدوله بل تؤمن بمفهوم الفوضى
رغم عمق الخلافات تبذل قيادات تحالف اداره
الدوله جهودا كبيره للخروج من هذه الازمه
قد تسفر عن انفراجه قريبه سامر الكبيسي
العربيه بغداد الى اربيل وينضم الينا من
هناك القيادي في حزب الاتحاد الوطني
الكردستاني محمود خشنه واهلا بك معنا سيد
محمود بعد مرور خمسه اشهر على بدء العام
المالي ما زالت الموازنه لم تمرر برايك هل
هي انقلاب على حكومه اشياء السوداني كما
يراها البرزاني ام يعني من الاطراف التي
يتهمها بقوله هذا تحديدا
تحيه لك يوم للمشاهدين العربي انا لا
اعتقد بانه اجهاض بحق سيد محمد شيعه
السوداني لان هو جزء من الاطار التنسيقي
ولا ننسى بين يوم امس كان هناك اجتماع
للاطار التنسيقي بحضوره السيد محمد الشيعه
السوداني وربما هناك خلاف واختلاف ما بين
مقترح اللجنه الماليه ومقترح الحكومه وهذا
الاختلاف يعود الى ان مقترح الحكومه تعتمد
على الاتفاق السياسي بين حكومه الاقليم
والحكومه الاتحاديه التي ابرمت في 14
ابريل الماضي ومقترح اللجنه لكن انا اعتقد
بان اثاره حفيظه الاخرين والترويج
والتسويق والتصعيد بهذا الشكل غير مبرر
لان اصلا هناك سيتم التصويت على مقترحين
مقترح اللجنه ومقترح الحكومه ما حصل في
اللجنه الماليه من مقترحات هي تعود الى
مقترح اخر وليس التعديل لمقترح الحكومه
سيتم التصويت على احد المقترحين لذلك
نحتاج اذا ارادوا ان
يجهضوا مقترح اللجنه الماليه يجب ان
يذهبوا الى حشه اصوات لدعم مقترح الحكومه
بالتالي سيكون التصويت على المقت يعني اما
مقترح الحكومه او مقترح اللجنه لكن انا لا
اعتقد بان اصل المشكله تعود الى قضيه
الاختلاف في قانون الموازنه اما هي قضيه
الصلاحيات والعوده الى ملفات سابقه ما
يثير حفيظه الاخوه في الديمقراطي وليس كل
الاحزاب الكرديه بالمناسبه الاتحاد الوطني
حركه التغيير حركه الجديد العمل
الكردستاني الاتحاد الاسلامي الكردستاني
وحركات سياسيه اخرى ليس لدي هذه الوجهه في
التعامل مع ما حصل من مقترح اللجنه لان
فيها امور ايجابيه لكن ما يثير حفيظه
الاخوه في الحزب الديمقراطيه الكرساني هي
بالتحديد الماده 14 اولا تاسعا عاشرا حادي
عشر ثاني عشر
امام 13 تتعلق بالفقره الثانيه من فقره جي
من الماده الثانيه هذه الامور انا
باعتقادي فيها جوانب ايجابيه ايضا بما
يتعلق باعاده واسترجاع عدد ادخار الاجبار
الرواتب الموظفين فهي بها جنب ايجابيه
والامور التي تتعلق برواتب الموظفين
والمتقاعدين واعطاء الاول ويه لرواتب
الموظفين المتقاعدين اما اكثر نقطه يعني
هم يختلفون عنها هي قضيه الحقول النفطيه
التي لم تعلن صراحه لم يتكلم عنها الكثير
بالتالي اذا ماده 14 وبالتحديد عاشرا تفضل
وبالتحديد عاشرا في الماده 14 وبالتحديد
فقره عاشرا يتكلم عن ان تكون ضمن اقلام 14
برميل التي الزم فيها حكومه اقليم بتصدير
عبر شركه سومو ان لا تكون الحقول النفطيه
الموجوده في كركوك
وهذه المشكله المشكله الحقيقيه في اثاره
الحفيظ حفيظه الاخرين والذي لم يتقبلوا
هذه المشكله الحقيقيه
هل نحن امام ازمه سياسيه جديده بين اربيل
وبغداد
انا اعتقد بان الانقسام السياسي الداخلي
في اقليم كورسان اثر على اداء حكومه
الاقليم التشضي السياسي الداخلي في اقليم
كورسان
والقرارات المنفرده من بعض الاطراف ولا
ننسى بان الاتحاد والديمقراطي الان ليسوا
في جبهه واحده هناك مستجدات قضائيه
مستجدات برلمانيه
في 48 او 72 ساعه الماضيه التي ادت
بالتالي الى ضعف تواجد اقليم كردستان
وحضوره السياسي والاداري في بغداد وهذا
الانقسام وهذا التشضي ادى على يعني اثر
كثيرا على على مقترحات اللجنه ادى على
التمرير الموازنه وسيؤثر لاحقا ايضا اذا
لم نذهب الى حلول عقلانيه لذلك المشكله
الحقيقيه اضافه الى ما وجد في مقترح
اللجنه الماليه ومسوده قانون الموازنه هي
مشكله سياسيه المشكله السياسيه تكمن
بالعلاقات الكرديه الكرديه قبل ان تكون
علاقه اقليم كرسان مع الحكومه الاتحاديه
لذلك اذا اردنا معالجه هذه الازمه يجب ان
نذهب الى معالجه سياسيه ومن ثم مع الشركاء
لا ننسى بان في الساعات القليله القادمه
سيكون هناك اجتماع لائتلاف اداره الدوله
الحاكم ربما
ينقل بقرارات او الامور التي ذكرت يوم امس
في في اطار التنسيقي وستبقى وتم تبحث عنها
في اجتماع اداره الدوله
مصير هذه الموازنه يعني هل ستمرر في نهايه
المطاف ام ستظل هذه المعضله والازمه
السياسيه بين اربيل وبغداد شكرا جزيلا لك
القيادي في حزب الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني
محمود خوشنا
نتوقف مشاهدينا مع هذه الصور للهجوم
الروسي منذ قليل على كييف وتصدي الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه للهجمات المكثفه المكثفه
او الاوكرانيه تتصدى للهجمات المكثفه
المتتاليه على العاصمه هناك اعلان لحاله
التاهب وانذار جوي فكيف ومحيطها تقارير
اوكرانيه اشارت بسماع عدوي انفجارات فيكيف
هذه الصور اتتنا قبل قليل من الهجوم
الاخير المكثف من موسكو على العاصمه
سلطات كيف مشاهدينا تؤكد استمرار الهجوم
الروسي العنيف منذ يومين وحتى اللحظه على
العاصمه كييف والتصدي له عبر الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه دعونا نستمع قليلا الى
هذه الهجمات
[موسيقى]
من الاجهاد او محاولات روسيا لاجهاد
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه الى اجهاد من نوع اخر
حذرت دراسه حديثه نشرها المرصد الفرنسي
للاغراق المعلوماتي والتعاون الرقمي من
الادوات التكنولوجيه التي اصبحت تشغل
مساحه اكبر في اماكن العمل حيث تؤدي دورا
مساعدا للموظفين في القيام بمهامهم لكنها
تحمل ايضا مخاطر الاجهاد الرقمي
تنتشر الاجهزه الالكترونيه في البيوت
والاماكن العامه والاكثر في مقرات العمل
خاصه مع الاعتماد عليها بشكل شبه كامل
دراسه حديثه حذرت من هذه التكنولوجيا
مشيره الى ان
31% من الموظفين
يفرطون في استخدامها ما قد يؤدي الى حاله
عزله بسبب الضغط الذهني فلا يوم عمل يمر
دون ارسال بريد واستقبال اخر
قلبت الحياه اذا ما قلنا سهلتها ولكن هل
تنقلب الى نقمه الاطباء حذروا من حمى
التكنولوجيا فالاجهاد الرقمي برايهم بات
خطرا اخذا في التمدد لاسيما عقب جائحه
كورونا التي اجبرت الكثيرين على المكوث
طويلا خلف الشاشات حد الاعتماد عليها في
شتى المجالات اي انها مشقه رقميه كما اطلق
عليها
مرتبطه بامراض القلب والاوعيه الدمويه
فضلا عن التمثيل الغذائي والتاثيرات
المناعيه الى جانب الضغط النفسي الذي يقلل
من الاداء المهني
من عمان ينضم الينا مستشار العلاج الدوائي
السريري الدكتور ضرار بلعاوي اهلا بك معنا
دكتور يعني بعد كورونا دكتور توجهنا كثيرا
لاستخدام الاجهزه الالكترونيه والشاشات
اجتماعات دراسه معلومات يعني واجهات عمل
كثيره يعني تستخدم التكنولوجيا والشاشات
هناك اثار جانبيه بدانا نلتمسها يعني هناك
التعرض لحم التكنولوجيا بالتالي سؤالي
دكتور ما ابرز الاثار والاضرار التي
لمستموها
تحياتي يا سيدتي لك وللمشاهدين الكرام
الحقيقه انه الاجهاد الرقمي هو جزء من
الاجهاد الوظيفي بشكل عام والاجهاد
الوظيفي امر مدروس وعليه ابحاث كثيره ونحن
يعني الحقيقه نرشده يوميا من قبل المرضى
الاجهاد سته الرقمي او الاجهادي اللي هو
جزء من الجهاد الوظيفي هو انه حجم العمل
يزيد عن قدرتنا في التعامل معه فاحنا مثلا
اذا تحدثنا عن الاجهاد الرقمي بالتخصيص
نتحدث عن انه نحن دائما امام الشاشه انا
الان بتحدث مع حضرتك امام الشاشه دائما
معي موبايلي ممكن خلال خمس دقائق واحد يرن
علي الزوم بدنا نعمل هذا الضغط يا ستي
اللي اصبحت خلال كورونا وبعد كورونا
باستخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ووسائل
الاجتماع عن بعد سبب ضغط
ذهني وضغط على حتى الاجهزه العضويه مثل
النظر حتى اثر على
يعني الوزن واحد صار يجلس امام الكمبيوتر
بالساعات وبالتالي الحركه قلت وبالتالي
صرنا نشوف السمنه يعني زياده وزن عند كثير
من الناس
يعني زياده في حالات
والرقبه نعم بالاضافه الى طبعا الام في
الرقبه تشنجات في الاكتاف كما تفضلتي
دسكاد كل هاي يعني سببها الحقيقه انه احنا
دخلنا في حلقه اخرى
ربما تتطلب استخدام الشاشات والتكنولوجيا
والالكترونيات اكثر من غيرها مثلا ما ان
تناولنا غرفه الاخبار التي اتواجد بها
يعني نتعامل مع الشاشات بشكل كبير جدا في
مكان العمل في المنزل لمتابعه الاخبار
واماكن عمل اخرى ايضا تتطلب بذلك بالتالي
ماذا تنصح العاملين في هذه الاماكن
دائما انا انصح بانه يعني بالعاميه الواحد
يفقد شوي عن عن هاي البيئه يفطر شوي كيف
يعني انا والله دائما على شاشه الكمبيوتر
لازم اقفل الحقيقه اللابتوب لمده مثلا نصف
ساعه اعمل تقريبا استرخاء نفس الشيء اذا
شفت انه مثلا عم بيجيني مكالمات من من
مثلا على الزوم او على سكايب لا بسكره
لانه انا مثلا مركز بشغله ثانيه عم بقرا
فيها يجب علينا في مرحله من المراحل ان
ناخذ جزءا من الوقت للاسترخاء واحد يروح
يمشي ربع ساعه حول المبنى حول المكان اللي
هو بيشتغل فيه هاي الامور مهمه جدا حتى لا
ندخل في مرحله احتراق او اجهاد وظيفي بسبب
اللي هو الاتصال
ما يؤدي الى الاجهاد
التاثير على الكفاءه وجوده العمل يعني الى
جانب التاثير على الصحه التقرير يشير
والدراسه تشير الى انه ايضا يؤثر على جوده
العمل وكفاءه بالتالي كيف الاجهاد الذهني
يؤثر على كفاءه العمل وعلى جودته
السته بالاضافه للامراض العضويه اللي ممكن
يسببها لحكينا عنها الام في الرقبه ودسكات
ومش عارف ارتفاع في ضغط الدم والسكري
والسمنه كمان احنا في عنا ضغط ذهني فبصير
الانسان يعني مشوش دهنيا غير قادر على
اتخاذ القرارات انا يا ستي لم يجيني 40
ايميل ولا خمسين ايميل باليوم ما بستطيع
زي ما يجيني ثلاث اربع ايميلات افكر فيهم
احللهم ثم اعطي القرار فبصير في عندي
تشويش بصير في عندي صعوبه في اتخاذ القرار
حتى انه بعض الدراسات رصدت حالات من
اضطرابات القلق صار عندي قلق صار عندي خوف
انه هلا بجيني ايميلات كيف بدي اخلصهم
وبالتالي صار في عندي الناس اضطرابات في
المزاج مثل الاكتئاب هذا
كله كيد المشكله مشكله لانه اضطرابات
النفسيه تؤدي الى زياده في اضطرابات
العضويه مثل الضغط والسكري نعم جزيلا لك
من عمان مستشار العلاج الدوائيه السريري
دكتور ديرار بلعاوي
ختام النشران نذكر بالعناوين
طرفان نزاع السوداني يبحثان تمديد الهدنه
في جده اليوم وشروط جديده على طاوله
التفاوض
توتر متزامن في ليبيا اشتباكات عنيفه في
طرابلس وغارات لليوم الرابع على مدينه
الزاويه
تحت شعار مئويه تركيا اردوغان يدشن حقبه
جديده واكلجار اوغلو يتوعد بمواصله الكفاح
الموازنه تشعر ازمه جديده بين بغداد
واربيل والاخيره تحذر من الاخلال بالاتفاق
السياسي
الزميلي في الاحمر معكم على راس الساعه في
امان الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات